Wade: I'm a rabbit and I can only jump
one inch?
Mark: Yeah...
Jack: Yeah it seems-
Bob: Kinda like...
Jack: Oh hey!
Bob: You're kinda like a little hamster
Bob: Oh hey what's up fellers?
Mark: Oh hey- hey guys how's it goin'?
Jack: Hello *laughs*
Mark: What the fuck- hello
Bob: Wait wait, wait everyone shut up
Mark: Okay
Bob: Jack, jump!
Jack: Wait I have to turn up my sound
because it's adorable
Jack: Er, eh, wuh
Bob: Okay, and Mark is this you then,
over here?
Mark: Hup!
That's me!
Bob: Where the fuck's Wade?
Wade: Are you guys close to the building?
Jack: Wade's over here, Wade turn right!
Jack: We're over here!
Jack: At the green thing!
Mark: Wade, we're squeaking
Bob: Go towards the squeaking
Jack: Go left, left
Mark: Make a left, make a left, make a left
Bob: Squeak furiously!
Mark: NONONONO
Mark: Towards the building! NOOOO! WADE!
Jack: Over here!
Wade: I see you, I'm on my way!
Mark: Okayyyy!
Bob: *uncontrollable laughter*
Wade: Well Jack said go right, so I turned right!
Jack: Yeah, not fucking 180 degrees!
Wade: I went 90 degrees right!
Bob: You did not, you were like
Bob: It's like, "Go right"
Bob: "Okay, this wayyy!"
Bob: "No, go left!"
*heavy laughter*
Bob: "Okay, this wayy!!"
Wade: I was looking at the building and went that way!
Jack: We're extraordinarily cute, but fucking slow
Mark: Yeah
Bob: Yes we are, I think that's part of the whole thing
Wade: There's someone else here!
Mark: I think that's probably fine
Wade: Let's fuck 'em up!
Bob: Oh wait they're bots, they're bots, they're bots
Jack: Uh-oh...
Wade: Oh God I'm drowning
Mark: Ohh are we supposed to go towards the building or is that gonna kill us?
Wade: I think so
Bob: I'm gonna go towards the building
Mark: Alright Bob, you do that
Jack: I don't know what's happening
Wade: Must obey!
Jack: Somebody's just here, shoot 'em down
Bob: I, I.. I'm--
M: Holy shit
Wade: Oh my god the building looks like a cow-pig!
Bob: I'm just gonna say, I don't know much about this game
Jack: This is fucking haunting
M: Oh...
Mark: There's an ominous noi-OHHHH
Wade: AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Jack: Jesus Christ! Fucking hell!
Bob: oOH HOOO HO HO OHHHHHH
Bob: OH HEYY
Wade: What?
Mark: Wooooah!
Wade: It's possible to crash the star ship?!
Mark: AGHH why?!
Bob: *surprised panicked noises*
Jack: Oh... Bob, Bob? Can you--?Ah Jesus Christ!
Mark: Bob why did you do that?!
Wade: "A balanced dropship is a happy ship"?
Bob: Oh my god I'm dy- everything I do kills you!
Wade: Wait guys there's a balance, balance!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Oh, we need to crash it
Mark: We need to crash it; get over on this side
Bob: Wait, who is this?
Mark: Guys, get over on this side
Bob: Who's...
Jack: Why do, why do we need to crash it?
Mark: Because it said you need to crash to escape!
Wade: But it says "A happy dropship..."
Jack: But it says "A balanced dropship is a happy dropship"
Jack: We're all gonna die!!
Wade: *shrieks*
Jack: Ahhh!
Mark: No, you seeee?
Mark: Woooah...Oooh!
Jack: Okay what do we do, what did we get?
Mark: I'm bringing...! *laughs*
Bob: Bring me all that shit into the green box
Mark: I'm bringing it!
Bob: Or I'll fucking murder you
Wade: How do you grab?
Jack: Oh god, oh god, okay
Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Oh jeezus!
Jack: We'll obey! Jesus Christ!
Bob: OBEY ME!!!!
Mark: Okay...
Jack: This is fuckin' terrifying!
Wade: who's going back to the drop ship, but not carrying anything?
Mark: It doesn't, it doesn't go up-- No, I'm not doing anything!
Bob: Hey! Hey. Heyyy...
Jack: Wait. Where do we bring it?
Jack: Where do we bring it?
Bob: In the green box, right there
Mark: It's not doing it
Bob: Nope nope nope
Jack: "You can only carry up to 3 items"
Wade: Oh, right click
Mark: Right click, got it got it
Jack: Ahhhh
Bob: Thank you
Bob: Thank you, you know what? Money for you...
Wade: Wait are you...?
Mark: Oh!
Mark: We deposited something for no autopay; we probably shouldn't do that
Mark: Hey, we demand FAIR PAY and FAIR WAGES!
*chuckling*
Bob: Hang on, hang on, right right right, right right
Jack: Minimum wage please!
Mark: I don't know...
Bob: "Action - Mouse 0" What is mouse zero?
Jack: Woooooo!!
Wade: Oh
Bob: *panicked* Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry!
Mark: Woah hohohohooo! My god!
Jack: Bob,-- oh Jesus Christ!
Bob: Sorry, sorry! sorry
Jack: Fucking hell!
Jack: Relax!
Mark: Oh Jesus
Wade: Erm, I think I'm carrying a missile?!
Bob: Everything is death!
Bob: God sakes!
Mark: Hohohoho
*All breathe*
Wade: Don't shoot me, don't shoot me!
Bob: Alright, I need to--
Jack: Okay
Jack: Okay, I don't know what's happening
Bob: Hang on, I'm looking--
Jack: "Can we have some obedience payment, Overlord Muyskerm?"
Jack: The bot is asking you something
Bob: I'm, I'm working on it
Bob: I-I...*sigh*
J: It's really terrifying that it looks like you have a face, two diddies and a dick
W: "Two diddies"?
M: Heh, the gun is your girthy-- gAh OHHHH FUCK
M: What did I do?!
J: *laughter*
B: *short, surprised breaths*
M: WHAT DID I DOOOO?!
J: *still laughing at Mark's death*
J: You got too close!
M: I wasn't even close, I was around the side!
W: Ahhhhhhhhhh!
B: Oh, you're... I--
B: I didn't even do that, you ran into the electrical things
B: I... How do I fucking give you money?
W: What do we-what even is this?
B: Oh! Oh, hey wait
B: Hey, who's this? Hey, you here.
J: Me! It's me!
J: It's Jack!
B: It's you, that's you?
J: Oh gee, that's not good
B: Money
B: Money for you! Nonono, stay still, stay still
B: I figured it out, money for you
B: Now you have money. Maybe.
J: Do I?
J: I do! I have $37
J: Ooh $373! Bob--
B: There's some money on the ground. Go get it Jack, I gave you money. Alright, everyone...
M: Yeah I have $314, $315...
J: Oh, dropship
B: Alright, get the dropship stuff and bring it to Bob
W: Yeah... woOOOOO!
M: Ok, AHHHH! Heh heh
B: I know how to give you money now
M: Bring it to Big Daddy Bob
J: Oh my god
J: Look at all this shit
B: Bring it right there
M: I'm bringing it! I'm bringing it!
W: We're bringing it Bob!
B: Right there
M: We're bringing it!
W: We're bringing it!
*mark and wade sob*
J: *giggles*
B: Good job! Good job everybody
B: Here, I'll put some money down for you, good job everybody
J: Thanks
W: Thank you Bob
B: There's some money-
J: Thank you Overlord Bob
B: Here you go, here you go fellas
M: Ooooooh!
B: There's some money for ya
M: Oh thank you!
J: Money, money, money, money
B: Bring it all right there, if you would please
W: Yeah w-we're bringing it
B: Hey, whoever's still carrying shit, you fucking bring that before you get money, alright?
M: I'm bringing it... I, I'd just-!
M: That was on my second pass; I was bringing more!
J: Haha ha
W: YEAH!
B: I, I gave you--
W: We made two trips!
B: I gave you money, I gave you money, I gave you money
J: Wait, how do we buy shit?
B: You don't buy shit, I buy shit
J: I think you buy it on the dropship
B: I buy it
M: Ohh
W: You buy stuff with OUR money?
B: No, I have my own money
J: There were prices on the dropship when I looked inside it
W: Yeah but we have money too
B: Yeah so, I wasn't gonna say this until I had a really substantial lead...
B: Your goal is to take over this tower from me, just FYI
W: Well yeah, but how? We can't get close!
J: How?
M: Well how do we do that?
B: You have to walk in the front door, sneaky sneaky like
J: This is fuckin'-- Oh, ahHAHAHAH
W: I don't know how we do that
B: Sneakier than that!
M: Like this?
B: Oh shit!
B: Oh god!
J: Yeah sneaky like- BOOOOM
M: *still heartily laughing*
W: *shrieks*
B: Goddammit
J: See, wait, look!
B: Wait, so we should crash the dropship, everyone crash it. Fuck this
J: Look here! It gives us places
B: Don't let Mark get all these resources, fuck it
B: Crash the dropship
J: OH GOD! FUCK! JESUS CHRIST!
W: Uh--OH NOO! I wanted to buy...oh
M: *laughing*
W: Wha- I'M BACK HERE AGAIN!!!
B: OH MY GOD.
M: *giggly bitch*
J: There's a buncha shit in here!
B: Holy...
M: *bellows* GIVE ME RESOURCES
W: Oh, nooo!
*All laughing*
B: Holy. Fucking. Shit.
M: Oh my god
W: What have we done?!
M: I don't know! *laughs*
B: Yeah, why did we let...
J: Why do I have...
J: I have like, no money anymore!
M: Yeeeah, what the fuck?
M: Alright so, alright
J: What is this crap?
W: You bought something
M: Alright Bob, tell me what I'm s'pposed to do
B: Okay basically every button except for "V" is murder
B: You hold V to put little pointers on the map
B: And to give out money to people
M: V doesn't seem to do that for me
J: Oh wait!
J: Mark's in the thing now? OHHH we're floating
B: Or C, it might've been C
B: It might have been C, it might have been C
J: Ohhh we're floatin'
M: Oh you're right it's C
W: Crash the ship!
W: Crash the--!
J: Oh we've got a significant imbalance--
M: Woah oh *breaks into laughter*
W: Oh god!
J: Jesus Christ!
M: Oh, Bob made it in
J: Fuckin' hell!
B: Did you guys...
J: Okay!
B: Did you guys crash my ship?
B: Hey look, get that stuff, I'm back in control, I'm not gonna murder you, I'll give you MONEY
J: Ok
M: Ha hah ha
M: Ohh, okay, alright
B: I will give you many moneys
J: Thank you, thank you Overlord Bob--
M: Bob
B: I am a benevolent overlord
J: YOU JUST KILLED ME
B: I did not! You got too close to the laser thing
M: Bob!
J: Which means you killed me!
J: I will say, it's very pretty
W: Wait, what are these metal pieces going in?
M: Bob!
B: Here. Money. Money.
B: Money! What?
M: I have an obedience collar, do you need money?
J: Hey, I'm so far away!
B: Umm, you can put the collar on, that'd be fine
M: Okay, it's already on, I got it
B: Eh-Wait, who's this-
B: Who's this person who doesn't have a collar?
B: Who the fuck is that?
B: You.
B: You!
J: I-I'm comin'!
J: I need an obedience collar!
J: You killed me and now I'm all the way over here
M: I'm dropping off, don't worry! I'm dropping off!
M: Don't kill me, don't kill me
J: Oh, wait, wait!
J: I got it, I got it
M: There you go!
B: Good job, you guys
B: I'll give you money, my little servants
M&W: Thank you!
W: Thank you
J: Give ME money!
J: I have, like, no money anymore
M: Ah...
B: You gotta give me-
W: Thank you
B: You've gotta drop me shit- hey, who's this?
B: Who's this?
M: Eh
B: Who is that shit with no obedience collar?
J: Not me!
B: Who are you?
M&J: *laughing*
B: I will fucking end you!
J: You can't put money ON the drop thing, we can't get that!
B: Oh, sorry, I'll put some more
B: I'm rich, so it's fine
B: Here you go, friend
M: Comin' back!
M: Woooahh
B: Ah! Shitsnacks
B: Who just-- oh
J: FUCKING JESUS CHRIST!
M: WAAAAAGGGHH
W: HEY BOB!!
B: *laughing*
W: HEEEYY
B: *giggly* Wade
M: nO, I'M...WADE! DON'T KILL ME
M: I'M DROPPING OFF, I'M DROPPING OFF!!
J: Oh god
W: Alright
M: I'M DROPPING OFF!
B: Alright, Wade
M: THANK YOU
J: This is fucking terrifying!
B: I-
M: *freaking out* I'm putting on an obedience collar!
W: *laughing* GET ME STUFF
B: *laughs*
M: I PUT IT ON
J: *laughs*
B: Wade, I'm the one that's far away, I have a collar on
J: *shhh*
B: Don't kill me, I bring you resource
B: I am here, I bring you resource
M: I bring- I bring you everything you want
M: I give you BEST resource
W: You better!
M: Oh, resource gonna taste so GOOD
B: I was g-oh, shit, how do I get
B: How do I pick stuff up? Okay, there we go
M: Ooh
W: I don't know how to do anything here,
W: but don't take that as a-
M: AH!! WHYY?!
W: Oh
M: What did I do?!
B: *laughing*
M: I GAVE...
W: I wanted to see what would happen!
J: *laughs*
M: I GAVE YOU RESOURCES!
B: Wade, if you, if you push-
W: Oh, well...
B: OH MY FUCK
J: GET REKT BITCH
W: Hi Jack!
M: Ohhohoho, noo
J: Oh, GOD, this is scary
J: DIEEEE MOTHERFUCKERS
B: No, no no, NO NO NO!
M:NOOO!!!
W: WHAAAT, OHHHH
M: I'M GETTING YOU SHIT!
B: I have an obedience collar!
J: Who's over here?
W: *shrieks*Jack!
B: I'm doing it!
J: Who's over here?!
W: *shrieks*JACK!
M: I'm just getting you shit (x3)
B: Jack, don't be like that! I'm doing it, look, look
B: I have a collar
M: I love you
B: I have a collar, I'm going
J: Okay
B: That person doesn't have a collar
J: Ok, who's coming in, who's coming in
J: Who're those two?
B: That- this person right here
M: I DIDN'T HAVE A COLLAR
M: THERE WAS NO COLLAR AROUND HERE
M: GIVE ME YOUR DAMN COLLAR
B: You just-
M: GIVE ME YOUR COLLAR
B: You just put one in the machine, you dumb!
M: NO I DIDN'T, I DIDN'T HAVE ONE ON
J: Okay okay okay
B: Oh no! I just deposited my collar, I'm sorry
B: I'm sorry Overlord
M: See! He-he-he's
J: It's okay, it's okay, have some money!
J: Have some money!
M: He's a betrayer
B: Ooh, ooh, money!
J: Yeah!
M: Heh, Jackieboy's the worst overlord I've ever seen
W: Heyy Jack!
W: UHH
M: Don't kill!
M: I've got goodies for you!
M: Kill AFTER I deposit the goodies-
W: DON'T KILL, KEEP ALIVE-
W: AHHH!!!
J: OH! OHHH!!
B: *giggling* Ohhh my god!
M: *AFTER* I DEPOSIT THE GOODIES
M: Jesus!
J: I didn't know what it did!
B: *laughing*
M: IT KILLS!
J: I- I'm sorry!
B: Here, I'll finish the job that these-
W: You murdered the shit out of me!
B: I'll finish the job that this traitor was incapable of doing
J: Ohh! I'm autopaying you, look!
B: Oh, shitsnacks!
B: Autopay is the best
B: How'd you do that?
W: Bob, you've got so much money!
J: You just press D
B: Yeah, I-I took a substantial lead before I told you guys the rules of the game, sorry
J: Okay, nothing can be purchased until the drop ship is purchased
J: Ohh, okay
W: Yeah, you gotta-
W: How do you earn money if you can't get a drop ship?
J: Yeah, I don't have $15,000!
B: Well if you let me take control, I'll buy a drop ship
B: Since I'm rich
M: HA-HA!
J: aHahaa, I knew someone was gonna sneak in!
M: *giggles*
B: Alright Mark, so you gotta buy a drop ship first-
M: How do I do that?
B: -but you don't have money for that
B: P, I think it said, was drop ship
J: P, yeah
W: You have money, he's got $18,000
J: it's at the top of your screen
J: Whoa, that's a terrifying light
M: Wait... You guys...
M: You guys need to put on your obedience collars!
J: Shine it on me again!
B: I'm working on it
J: I got it!
B: I'm workin' on it!
J: Ahh!
W: I-I just deposited mine
M: Did you?
M: In which depository?
B: *laughs*
J: I'm over here!
J: There's an obedience collar over here, who needs it?
W: I'm right here, I'm right here, this is me!
M: Where?
W: I deposited-ed-ed right here
M: Ohh, okay
J: I have two!
J: I have two
M: I see you guys
M: I see you
M: Where you guys goin-
M: Who's tryin' to sneak in?!
B: Are you gonna order stuff or what
M: How do I do that
B: You hit the numbers, and then,
B: and you have to buy a dropship first                                J: Middle of... the top middle of your screen
B: But then you hit the numbers that it says on the top of the screen
M: Okay got it! dropship on route
J: Yeah go in to the purple flame, it gives you like.. money
M: Does it?
M: Wait!  I see-
M: Who's over there, Who's over there!
M: Who's over there!! AH!
J: What the fuck!
M: Who's over there!!!
B: *laughing*
M: Who's doing that!!
M: I saw that!
B: I think you're going crazy Mark
M: Nonononono!
M: I-i-i know there's treachery
M: I KNOW there's treachery
M: Alright, don't deposit the collars
M: Keep the collars on
B: Mark can you buy me a collar i'm in the dropship dude you may have killed me
M: whoooo's there
B: You killed me
M: Too close for COMFORT
W: *inaudible "whooh!"*
J: Christ that scared me
W: Yeah it is
J: stop obeying bunniplier
B: Alright everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone uhh.. oh hey collar gimme that
B: aw i can't pick it up in the dropship
B: Hey should we crash this fucker
M: no no no
B: Fuck Mark
B: let's crash this bitch
M: i'm watching you guys
J: i still don't understand this game * laughs *
M: * laughs *
B: so the point is to get money
B: when you're, when you're the overlord you passively get money
J: you have 63 hundred dollars (6,300)
J: or cents i guess...
B: shhhhhhhh...
W: Hey i also learned something else
M: yeah?
W: depositing corpses hurts.... you
B: * laughs *
M: Wait WHAT?!?!
B: ohh that's cool
M: I'm at negative 15 hundred dollars!! (-1,500)
B: Oh my god!!! HA HA
M: Fucking.. DON'T YOU DARE
J: AH! Jesus christ!
M: *goofy laughter*
B: Jack! Jack let's crash it!
B: Let's crash it, quick! Come over here!
J: I'm trying!
M: *more goofy laughter*
B: Fuck this drop ship!
J: OK Am I-Am I on your head? AAAAH GOD!
B: Alright whatever
M: You guys better get me some money
M: Cause I am REALLY hurtin.
B: Look, I put my collar on
B: I put my collar on, this is fine
M: Good, yeah, sure, OK.
M: I see you hiding in that bush!
M: Who's hiding in a bush?!
M: I see yoooohoohoohoo *giggling*
J: *giggle*
B: Do you have auto-pay on or what, are you gonna pay me for this shit?
M: I-I don't know, I have no money how can I pay?
M: nO THAT'S A CORPSE
W: *giggling*
B: Hey, where...where'd that corpse go?
Everyone: *giggles*
J: He made a new corpse with the other corpse
B: *laughter*
M: Whaddaya doin? Whadday doin? Whaddaya doin?!
I SEE YOU IN THAT BUSH!!
M: NO!!
B: OHOHOH MY GOD *LAUGHTER*
M: *maniacal laughter*
W: Jesus...
B: Yeah Mark doesn't have shit.
M: You guys ca-WHAT the FUCK?!
J: Jesus fuckin christ!
B: Oh my god...
M: Oh geeze
J: Yay now we're on the drop ship again
B: The bot-The bot is now in charge
M: Oh shit that's not good
W: *SCREAMING*
Everyone: *is dying*
J: Good sound, good sound.
M: Good, good, good, I like this. OK. Alright.
J: We need to crash this, we'll have to wait
20 seconds otherwise.
M: Alright, ok, alright.
J: Crash it everybody up...somewhere.
M: We gotta pile up on one side.
Bob: We got get in and crash the shit out of this.
M: I got it.
B: You can do it.
Mark: Oooh.
M: I got over it.  Thanks guys.
W: NOOOOooooooo...
B: Yaaaaaaaaay
B: Bob is king!
W: noooo....
J: Kay, we're coming in.
J: Coming in hot!
B: There's a bunch of money on the ground! Everyone be cool...
B: Put your collars on our I will murder you.
M: I got it! Got it! My collar's on!
M: Collar's on!
J: AH... I- M: Dont kill me collars on!
B: which one of you fuckers doesn't have a collar...
M: Collars on!
B: One of you shitz doesn't have a collar
J: Ya I Cant pick it up...
M: you know what Bob... I'm gunna scout for you...
...If I see people commen after you...
...Imma let you know, Hows that?...
...Does that sound fair Bob?
B: Sure
J: Bob I think kill em' first
M: Noo!
B: Ya
W: Ya
B: Ya thats kinda...
J: Its always the right-hand man who deserts you
M: Nu-nu-nu no, come on now
... Come on now, come on guys, come on guys
J: Now we have nothing left to get, like...
M: WAIT SOMEONE'S COMING IN BOB SOMEONE'S COMING IN
BOB SOMEONE'S COMING IN
J: buhahaha
M: Bob, your-your-...
B: Where?
M: ... Your fucked.
B: Come in I fucking dare you
J: I'm not even tra-- IM LOOKING FOR NEW SHIT
M: Naw I'm not doing anything! N-no BOB!! AHH!!
J: For fook'sake!
M: Bob I, I hadda, I HADDA COLLAR!
B: You were carrying a corpse!
M: No I wasn't ;b *chuckles*
J: God all'mighty
M: uhhhh-
J: I hate obeying you guys
B: You just have to not be a scrub lord
M: Ye dude
W: YAA! SCUB LORD BAHAHAA
M: * HAHAHAAH*
J: * HAHAHAAH*
W: WHO'S THE SCRUB LORD NOW
J: King scrub lord
M: alright... WHY!?!?!?
B: This is horrible
J: HEY!
M: WHY!?!?
J: HEY! HEY! HEY!
M: *chuckles* why did you do that!?
W: Because I'm the o-
B: Are we crashing this bitch?
B: Lets crash this bitch!
M: Ya
B: Lets fucking do this
M: Theresa lota fuel. Thats probably not good
W: Theresa drop ship, bring me stuff!
J: I can't see where I'm going!
M: Alright, coming in! Coming in with supplies!
W: You got something on you!
J: Bye drop ship
M: Coming in with supplies. WITH supplies!
J: Don't shoot me!
B: Theresa a bunny...
B: Wade, there's a bunny in a bush right here.
M: ...What the fuck?...
B: You see me standing back here up to the left?
B: Over here.
B: There's a bunny in the bush right next to me, that red bush
W: Ok
B: Right there, theresa bunny J: ...Hiding on you
B: He's fucking hiding
B: I'm being good! See look,
B: Boop
J: AHAHAAA
M: Gosh jesus!
B: FUCK
M: Jeee-hehe-zzuuuss
W: NICE TRY
W: One of you's coming for me and I don't trust ya
M: Nu-nu no it's fine- J: We probably should've played the tutorial.
M: -It's fine dude... NO NO
M: Tutorials are for asshole's and losers
W: ALRIGHT GET BACK
M: WOOOW I wasn't cl-...
W: GET BACK
M: I wasnt close
W: *Grunts*
M: Alright
M: Wade, I'm gunna be your scout. I'm your scout, I love you
M: I love you
W: why are there so many dr-
J: Coming in hot
M: Woow
B: That sounds like the truth if i've ever heard it
W: DISOBEY WADE IZLE, KILL THAT... THING
M: Wade I love yo- J: I have items!
J: I have items don't shoot me!
B: Kill that bot fucker
M: I love you
J: I have items! You see me?
J: Imma squeaker
J: I have items
W: Wait who? WHO'S DOWN THERE I CAN'T SHOOT YOU ANYMORE
W: NOO!!!
M: No you're fine, you're fine Wade you're fine
B: Haha, it's fine Wade
M: Heh, you're fine
J: I like how there's a big pile of corpses by the enterance
M: Hehaha ya there's so many corpses  at the base
B: Wade there's nothing happening just realax
M: Ya Wade, we got-
M: WHY?  WHY!?
M: Jesus Crist
J: MOTHER FUCKER
M: Fuck you asshole
J: I didn't do anything
M: Jeeezus
M: So what we- So so here's the deal guys...
M: Imma place lights so they could see us better, so we could obey him better
M: Commin' in hot!
W: Woohoo
M: Alright...
M: Dont kill me Bob, don't kill me i'm placing lights for you look
B: I should- I Should of bought some colours i'm a idiot
M: Look look I'm- I'm putting lights down
M: See where I am? I'm over to you're left...
M: I'm putting a light right here
J: lu-LIES
M: Whoops, naw hang on...
B: You have to set it up man
M: There we go
M: See? Ya got a light now
B: Oh nice, nice
M: I'm gunna set you up another light
*Bob goes to speak* M: Wait. follow me...
B: Yey ya ya
M: Wait, Bob, follow me I'm coming-
J: Hi buddy!
M: - on your left I'm coming close, but not too close
M: I just wanna light by you so you always see this spot
M: Riiight-
J: I don't trust that Bob kill'em
M: - Right there, woO WO
M: WO WO WOO I'M SETTING YOU UP LIGHTS
B: I'm gunna shoot close to you, I'm not gunna shoot you. I  just want you to know
J: I have a obedience collar on Bob!
B: nice!
J: Do you love me most?
B: Ya- M: Bob is that good? Is that good light?
B: -Ya you're a good lil' bunny
M: ... good light. Do I get a reward?
M: Wait! Bob reward me I-I... I helped you
B: Where are you? Is this you?
M: Ya that's me
B: Here ya go
M: AHH!
M: FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU
M: I HELPED YOU! I BELIEVED IN YOU!
B: Hey, The auto-pay is cranked up right now so if you guys-
W: thats really good
B: -bring me alot
W: Really Glad
B: Ah shit!
J: Uh-oh uh-oh-
B: Fuck this!
B: Crash it! Crash this bitch! Fuck it!
B: Get over here
W: Don't crash it!
M: Bob I believed in you!
M: And. You know what. Fuck you!
M: Honestly- *All laugh* M: -Fuck you!
W: are you guys bringing me money?
B: What the FU-   M: I'm bringin' you money...
W: Thank you
M: Brought'cha money...  W: GOOD rabbit
*everyone talking at once*  B: DON'T SERVE WADE,
B: DON'T SERVE WADE HE'S--   W: BRING ME STUFFF.
M: *giggling*
B: Wade's a bastard! He kills you for no reason-  W: Wh-How!?  B: differently than me!
W: How do I turn on auto pay? I wanna pay you.
M: I think it's already on... WHOA that guy just burned. That bunny just literally burned alive right next to me
M: I don't- I have no idea why.
W: oh, well sucks to suck for that guy didn't it.
M: Oh geez. Don't touch that corpse, it's burning!
J: FUC- M: *laughing* GOD IT'S ON FIRE GUYS DON'T KEEP WALKING INTO THE FIRE.
J: Well I wanted to okay?!? *Mark laughs in the background*
M: This life sucks!!!   W: Alright, alright, I bought a bunch of stuff on this next drop ship,
M: Okay..
B: Wait, Wade, Wade, you just just asked in Voice Only how to turn on auto pay right?
W: yeah...?
B: Desbot just said "Wadeizzle: press D four times"
W: *soflty* what..?
J: THEY KNOW WHAT'S UP!
W: There you go- J: THE JIG IS UP
W: Alright, there you guys go!!
B: I'm so confused right now... W: Grab all that stuff!
B: I've already grabbed stuff- W: GRAAB ITT
M: I'm grabbing!! J: WHAT'RE YOU DOING??
B: Wade, if you endlessly kill us, we're obviously not-- W: I didn't kill anyone!  B:--not going to help you.
B: PAY ME.  W: I did! It's right there.
J: WHOA. MONEY.
M: *tries to say something*  J: I LOVE that shit!
W: Yeaaahh
B: I fucking LOVE monayyy.
M: *soflty over the chatter* Guys he hasn't noticed yet-  J: Wade, you have like, wayyyy less money than us now because you just-
J: Cranked it way up
M: *chuckling* Guys. He hasn't noticed yet
B: *laughing hysterically*
W: Haven't noticed what??
M and B: *both laughing* B: You're fucking broke!!
M: *giggling* Wade, wade look at your money- *Bob and Mark both crack up*
J: You've no money!!
W: HOW DARE YOU ALL YOU'RE GONNA PAY FOR THIS *Wade starts shooting, everyone is laughing and/or yelling*
W: YOU ALL DIEEEE
M: huahahhahahaha
J: Fuck's sake-  B: You know what? I was trying, now i'm just gonna fucking steal your thing
B: and kill you 'cause you're an idiot-
*Mark is still laughing*
M: dude,  W: You had auto pay on so high!  What happened?
W: I PRESSED THE D!!!
*Everyone laughs*
J: He wanted the D so bad!!
M: *giggling* Why- why would you blame us for that?!
W: I trusted you when you told me about the D!
M: I didn't tell you about the D, it was the bot! It wasn't us!
W: Can I shoot my own dropship?!?
M: I mean, sure?    B: Probably.